Hmm...
Yoisha!
Oh Kairi Nasaimase!
Goshujin Sama, Ojo Sama...
Hi, hello, my name is Mint Phantom.
I'm a new VTuber and welcome to my channel!
Yeah, woohoo!
Basha, basha!
So my name is Mint, I'm Forever 19, and I am an eternal
maid.
So just to introduce myself, since I'm new, uh, some things
that I really like are idols, anime, horror, bubble tea, and
most of all, most of all, most of all, most of all, maids
and cute girls.
My favorite foods are parfaits, ramen, and almond rice, but
I really dislike Masago and anything spicy.
I just, I just can't have it.
I'll, I'll die.
I'll, I'll die again.
I'll die.
So when I'm not haunting a maid cafe, I really just like to
watch idols and anime.
An idol group I love in particular Kistador.
You should definitely go watch their music videos.
And for my favorite anime, recently I really love Zombieland
Saga and ReZero.
And I basically also have seen basically every episode of
Detective Conan.
You know, when you're a ghost, you just have so much free
time on your hands.
So, I've never really been good at video games or speaking.
And so I thought, so I thought, so I becoming a VTuber would
help motivate me to get better about it and you know talk to
more people because I'm I'm very I'm very shy like think
think boo for Mario how he's so shy that's me don't look at
me look at me I want to play a lot of horror games even
though they really really do scare me I am gonna do my best
I think maybe if everyone's there watching with me it won't
be so scary I think.
My Japanese is okay.
I can try and say a little bit.
So there's a lot of things that I want to do and I hope that
I can get better with practice.
Please be patient with me.
with a full-time haunting and so you know it might take me
some time to get used to everything but I look forward to
talking with all of you and I really want to collab with all
the other VTuber cute girls I really do hope that I can
learn a lot though and also collaborate with other VTubers
and I hope you're looking forward to my content so thank you
so much for watching and I hope you'll follow me on Twitter
and subscribe to my channel for future videos and Yeah,
thanks for watching.
Um, I don't really know what else to say.
So...
Okay, bye.